what's going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard
and this is the channel where we talk
about all things data
data science statistics and programming
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this if you haven't already and hit
the notification bell so youtube
notifies you
whenever i upload a video so this is
going to be another video in my julia
tutorial series
in the first few few videos we worked
our way through getting set up in your
preferred environment
manipulating data and visualizing data
well today we're going to talk about
statistics specifically
working with some of your basic summary
stats all the various distributions as
well as setting up basic
statistical hypothesis tests now to do
this we're going to need to make use of
a variety of different packages
so first and foremost there's the
statistics package
but this is actually built directly into
base julia
meaning you don't have to go through and
run your package ad
statistics it's already gonna be built
in
there's the stats base uh package
and now the name to this is a little bit
misleading because
actually statistics is the package
that's built into base julia
but then the stats base package is going
to provide you with some optional
additional functionality on top of that
we're going to use the distributions
package for all of our
obviously distributional needs and then
finally we're going to wrap up with
hypothesis tests now if you've been
working your way through my other
tutorials there's some other
packages which i which i'm gonna bring
in like
first is the plots package that's pretty
straightforward
that's a simpler and quicker uh package
than something like
vega lite and then we also are gonna use
the random package for just some other
helper functions
before we go through all these things
though just a couple things
number one please smash the like button
it takes just
half a second of your time and it does
help my content reach a larger audience
also in the description of this video i
will have a link to my patreon account
so if you guys would be willing to
support me that way it would be
massively appreciated
this script is going to be just like
always available on my github repo which
will be in the description of the video
and then similarly i will have links to
a variety of these help documentation
files they'll be in the script as well
as like everything else
in the video description so without
further ado let's get started
alright so the first thing that we're
gonna work through are the various
distributions
and just like any uh other random number
generator type of problem
the first thing that we're gonna do is
set the random seed for reproducibility
purposes
and now from that random package that we
pulled in right up front
we have this seed function i'm going to
set the seed here to
just just just a random number 567
and then we're going to go from there
we're going to simulate
from some various statistical
distributions
now what we're going to do here to do
this is going
is to use this rand function
so the rand function is just for uh
sampling from something now how this is
going to work is
rand is going to take as its first uh
argument some data or a distribution
object
and so the distribution object that i'm
passing here is this normal distribution
the normal distribution has two
arguments that's
the mean 100 and the standard deviation
10.
that's going to give us a variance of 10
squared that is 100.
and then the second argument to the rand
function
is the number of observations so
basically all i want is 1 000
observations from a normal mean equals
100
standard deviation equals 10
distribution i'm going to use the plots
library to just use this histogram
function
that way i can look at my distribution
of data and
that to me looks incredibly normal
there's obviously many more
distributions that we can play with
using this package
the next one i'm going to show you is
the uniform distribution
so the uniform distribution has two
parameters
that's the minimum which i'm going to
set to 0 here and the maximum
we're going to set the 50. same thing
where we want 1000 observations from
this distribution
we'll make a histogram of that and again
that looks relatively uniform
next thing that i'm going to show you is
the exponential distribution
this has only one parameter and
we're going to set that to uh to 40
again
sample 1000 observations from that
distribution
now what we would expect here is
a long tailed sort of distribution
because the exponential distribution is
skewed to the right
that's exactly what we've got here now
continuous distributions are not the
only distributions that we can sample
from
we can also use uh discrete
distributions
so the big two that you're going to want
to be familiar with are the binomial and
the poisson
so in this example here what i'm going
to take is a binomial distribution with
n equals 30 and p equals 0.3
so just think of that as like 30
bernoulli trials with
the bernoulli parameter or probability
equal to 0.3
and then we're going to repeat that
entire process 1000 times
we're gonna create a histogram of that
naturally you would expect the mean of
such a distribution to fall
somewhere around nine that's precisely
what uh what we're getting here
then last thing that we're going to do
is 1000
uh observations from a poisson
distribution with parameter equal to
20. now in this instance we you would
expect
the mean to be somewhere around uh 20
and to have a somewhat more
asymmetric looking distribution and once
again that's exactly what we have here
now one last super useful functionality
that i'm going to show you from the
distributions package
is fitting the empirical distribution to
a theoretical distribution
so for those of you unfamiliar with
those terms an empirical distribution
can basically just be thought of as your
raw data
so if we look at our normal distribution
for example
this is not going to perfectly follow a
normal mean equals 100
standard deviation equals 10
distribution because
there's some degree of sampling error
from that right
and so we can take this raw data that
we've simulated
and then we can fit that to a
theoretical distribution
so if we do that we use this uh
fit function we want to fit uh to a
normal distribution
using our normal data and that returns
to us
a normal distribution with a mean that's
pretty close
it's like 99.966
and a standard deviation of 10.212
so it did a pretty good job we can do
something
very similar to that with the
exponential data and it returns to us
uh the theta parameter of 41.02 which
again is not
doing too bad considering uh the
distribution i was sampling from from
the first place
uh had the parameter of 40. so it's
doing a pretty good job
now that you've hopefully got the hang
of all the different distributions
let's work our way through some of the
statistics functions
and to do this i'm going to use if
you've seen my last tutorial the same
data set that i used there
i'm going to use this mpg data set that
comes from the ggplot2r package
so again that does rely on the r data
sets package
but i'm going to load that in into a
data set called mpg
then if i use the describe function on
that
the two variables that i'm going to
focus on here just for
giving you the idea of the statistics
functions are the cty
or city miles per gallon variable as
well as this hwy
that is highway miles per gallon so
remember up front i told you we've got
two different
stats packages those are statistics and
stats base
now if you want to specify where the
function is coming from
you can specify that package up front so
we can specify
statistics.mean of the city variable
coming from mpg
or we could use statsbase but it really
doesn't matter
because you can look at the output
that's returned here and it is exactly
the same
now julia is going to default to just
using the statistics package
uh if you just call mean so i would just
recommend doing that
the majority of the time because it
really doesn't matter but
all that to say you can specify
statistics or stats base
right up front now one of the helper
functionalities
that stats base is going to give us is
allowing us to do
like a weighted mean so this mean
function
is going to optionally allow us to pass
in
a vector of weight and now there's a
couple different ways that we could set
this up
so if we just want weights that add up
to
one we can use the a weights function
that's going to create what's basically
called an analytic
weights object it's a series of weights
that are going to add up to one
we pass that in as a second argument and
we see that the
weighted mean with 10 getting a weight
of 0.8
20 and 30 getting a weight of 0.1
that's going to return to us 13. now
similarly
if we want to define it instead as a
frequency
weight and now this is just think of
these as frequencies
so the number of times 10 20 and 30 are
occurring respectively
we could use this f weights function
which stands for
frequency weights we can set it up that
way and then
similarly we're going to get a returned
output of 13.
so it keeps going you have all the all
the different functions that you might
expect
we've got a median function we've got an
std
function that stands for standard
deviation obviously
there's a variance function for
returning our
variance and then we've got a super
useful quantile function
so first argument is going to be the
vector that you want to summarize over
and then the second argument is just
going to be a vector
for all your different quantiles that
you want to return
so i want the 0 10th percentile
25th 50th 75th
90th and uh 100th and then
i'm going to get all those we got 9 11
14
17 19 21 and 35 respectively
so super super helpful function just
like you might expect to see
uh if you were doing statistical
analysis in r now before we wrap up on
the statistics stuff let's get into some
of the more multivariate
type of things first and foremost i'm
going to create a scatter plot
of the variables city and highway
and it should come as no surprise to
anybody that these two things are highly
correlated right
so if you have a high city miles per
gallon you're probably going to have a
high highway miles per gallon
so these two things do look heavily
correlated
but we have this cor or core function
which can give us back our correlation
coefficient
so let's run that function and we get
a correlation of 0.96 thereabouts
and just looking at this that looks
just about right to me now if you want
to return the covariance
you can use this cov or cove function
we do that and we get a covariance of
24.2
roughly now the last thing to look at is
just how you sample from various data
and now there are two kind of similar
functions in julia
and the statistics and stat base
packages for this
those are rand and sample now there is a
subtle difference here
rand is purely for independent sampling
sample is a little bit more flexible so
we can do things that are
uh like things like sampling without
replacement which are
by definition not independent sampling
so i'm going to show you an example of
the sample function here
i want a sample from a vector that goes
1 through
50 i want to draw five items i'm going
to say
replace equals false so we're sampling
without replacement here
and we're going to order them so we can
specify to this argument ordered equals
true
let's do that and we drew the five
numbers 21
29 35 46 and 50. now the last thing that
i'm going to show you here is going to
be an example of a hypothesis test
and for this we are using the hypothesis
tests package
this is an extremely powerful package
you've got your standard parametric
tests like the t
the z the f and the chi square and you
have a whole
variety of non-parametric tests too
so i do strongly recommend reading the
documentation just so you're aware of
all the different things
you can do using this package but we're
gonna work through a simple
uh example from just a one sample t-test
using the same data that i used in my
statistics tutorial on hypothesis
testing
you have all your standard summary
statistic
data that you need for setting a
hypothesis test up well specifically a
one sample t-test
we have an x-bar of 3.2 a standard
deviation of 1.2
we have a sample size of 50. the mu
naught that we're testing against is 3.5
i'm going to create a hypothesis test
object
using this one sample t-test function
i'm going to feed to this function x-bar
the standard deviation
and and mu naught then i'm going to call
that test object
and we get a whole variety of really
awesome
uh output here we get our parameter of
interest here
that's the mean its value under the null
hypothesis
is 3.5 the point estimate that we
arrived at through our raw data
like our x bar was 3.2
uh the 95 percent confidence interval we
have is 2.859 to 3.541
and now we have a two-sided hypothesis
here although
you could specify that we want a left or
a right-sided test
uh but our outcome with ninety-five
percent confidence is that we fail to
reject the null hypothesis
and the two-sided p-value that we get
here is .0833
now we have all of our uh various
testing information here like we have 50
observations
the t-statistic that we got here was
negative 1.76
uh we have 49 degrees of freedom
and we have an empirical standard error
of 0.17 basically
and now there are a variety of helper
functions out there for extracting
different pieces of this output
but let's just say that i wanted the
left-sided
p-value here i can specify tail equals
left
to this p-value function here and then
i'm going to get a .0417
and in that instance assuming we had a
uh 5
significance level then yes we would be
rejecting the null hypothesis in this
scenario
so hopefully now you see all the
different things
in the statistics world that you can
accomplish using julia
i haven't shown you any modeling yet
because that's going to be the subject
for a different tutorial
but we've walked through distributions
the statistical functionalities
as well as the hypothesis test functions
now it
is entirely possible in the future all
the stats based functionality is just
going to be merged
directly into that statistics uh package
the one that is truly part of base julia
but as of now these two things are very
separate packages
so just be uh familiar with that fact so
thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please consider
sharing this video once again smash the
like button
and then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data